my fellow americans good afternoon
everybody good evening
good morning everybody
over the last several days we've seen
significant gains made by isil
a terrorist organization that operates
in both iraq
and in syria iraqi security forces have
proven unable
to defend a number of cities this is not
solely or even primarily
a military challenge but what's clear
from the last decade
is the need for the united states to ask
hard questions before we take
action abroad we're prepared to create
joint operations centers
in baghdad and northern iraq and we're
prepared to send a small number of
additional
american military advisors up to 300.
today i authorized
two operations in iraq targeted
airstrikes to protect our american
personnel
and a humanitarian effort to help save
thousands of iraqi civilians
who are trapped on a mountain without
food and water
and facing almost certain death
countless iraqis have been displaced
and chilling reports describe isil
militants rounding
up families conducting mass executions
when we have the unique capabilities to
help avert a massacre
then i believe the united states of
america cannot turn a blind eye
today the entire world is appalled by
the brutal murder of jim foley by the
terrorist group isil
there has to be a common effort to
extract this cancer so that it does not
spread
i don't want to put the cart before the
horse we don't have a strategy
yet isil poses a threat to the people of
iraq and syria
and the broader middle east including
american citizens personnel
and facilities left unchecked these
terrorists could pose a growing threat
beyond that region including to the
united states
i can announce that america will lead a
broad coalition
to roll back this terrorist threat
our objective is clear we will degrade
and ultimately
destroy isil through a comprehensive and
sustained
counterterrorism strategy we will
conduct a systematic campaign of
airstrikes against these terrorists
we will expand our efforts beyond
protecting our own people and
humanitarian missions
so that we're hitting isil targets as
iraqi forces
go on offense moreover i've made it
clear that we will hunt down terrorists
and threaten our country
wherever they are that means i will not
hesitate to take action against isil in
syria
as well as iraq may god bless our troops
and may god bless the united states of
america